you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with journalist and author christina
patterson and columnist for the times
and author matthew side
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the observer reports on fears amongst
conservatives that the party will suffer
a disaster at the next general election
over economic policy especially high
taxes and the chancellor's handling of
the cost of living crisis
the express claims an exclusive with
calls from a former minister that the
chancellor should seize back billions of
pounds in fraudulent covid loans as what
it calls a pain-free way to help ease
the crisis
the telegraph says the uk could build up
to seven new nuclear power stations in
its drive to wean the country off its
dependence on energy supplies from
russia
the sunday times reports on allegations
surrounding the conduct of tory mp david
warburton he's reportedly denied any
wrongdoing
the sunday people leads with a call to
catch what it calls the country's
cruelest burglars focusing on one victim
an elderly and frail man
while the star has a story about the
mother of baby p tracy conley who's
about to be released on parole
and the mirror also features baby p's
mother in a story involving justice
secretary dominic raab and the decision
to allow her parole
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and joining me tonight christina
patterson and matthew syde welcome to
you both um let's start with the uh
observer um and um
uh this story which is uh deeply
troubling russians use children as human
shields near kiev matthew
yeah truly dreadful
um we're in a critical moment in the
early stages of this war i think it's
obviously going much less well than
russia uh and putin had anticipated uh i
think he overestimated the strength of
his own military underestimated the
resolve of ukraine
uh overestimated the extent to which
ukrainian generals might change sides as
they had done
in crimea
and i think the risk always
is that if russia struggled they would
resort to more brutality um particularly
in terms of aerial bombardment but what
we're hearing in this story from the
observer in the next one uh in the
sunday times is as they're withdrawing
from kiev
kiev
they have used children
as
human shields
but they've also mined
corpses and there's some evidence of the
killing of civilians
in a way when the civilians were unarmed
so i think it just goes to the barbarism
that putin is resorting to to try and
achieve war aims that he thought would
be achieved far quicker yes a quote here
from uh
ukrainian
colonel saying that russian soldiers
have used ukrainian children as hostages
putting them on their trucks they're
doing it to protect their vehicles when
they're moving i mean they're obviously
taking
while putting together a dossier of
claims about how the russians have been
using uh children during uh this war and
this all feeds into to the war crimes
that that we know
are being committed
christina yes
i mean yes it's it's just it's utterly
heartbreaking the debts that putin and
his
armies are sinking to every day i mean
you you end up running out of words
actually to to talk about it because
it's just
my worry is as this continues on the
front pages day after day that we almost
become desensitized to the
horrors that are going on because
although it looks as though there is
some mild cause for
hope at the moment in that the russians
are retreating from kiev and the
ukrainians are putting up an incredible
fight the fact is that the likelihood is
that this war is not going to be over
anytime soon putin has made it
absolutely clear that he
he wants ukraine and
whatever terms if if he even
becomes serious about peace talks and i
think there's pretty much no evidence
that he's serious about p talks peace
talks at the moment
i can't see him wanting to give up
any of the land he's already got and he
clearly wants more and i can't see that
will be acceptable to president
zielenski or ukraine but in the meantime
putin is essentially making ukraine
uninhabitable it will be very very
dangerous for people to go
back there for a long time and we all
hope that there will one day it will one
day
we will see putin be tried for war
crimes in the way that we saw the nazis
tried
at nuremberg but i have to say that
i fear that real politic and the fear of
nuclear annihilation and the fear of
world war iii might get in the way of
that and i really hope that isn't the
case because we are literally seeing
genocide against the people of ukraine
and for them to be slaughtering and
torturing children and using them as
human shields is just beyond belief
uh matthew the sunday times gives
further gruesome detail about the the
mutilated bodies of children
yeah this is a first person piece
by the sunday times reporter louise
callahan and i must say a huge
admiration for the reporters who have
risked their lives to go in and give us
reportage from these these uh horrors
and she talks of a lady who lives in a
forest on the outskirts of kiev
and her neighbors in a neat brick house
four doors down had been tied hand and
foot and killed
and then a bit further down from there a
basement where 18 bodies of men women
and children as young as 14 lay dead
with their bodies mutilated
um
it's very very difficult to read frankly
i i went to the poland border uh with
ukraine and uh last week and and saw the
the persecute the tribulation that
people have endured to try and escape
this this hell
um and it's just quite quite shocking to
read what's been happening and
christine is quite right i hope we live
to see the day when putin is is put on
trial for the crimes that have been
carried out in his name yeah and a quote
from uh one of those people mentioned in
that report in the sunday times the
russian soldiers are lower than animals
animals don't do what they did we
shouldn't take them hostage they must
die they must be destroyed
i mean what what is what well what is
tragic actually is
the
the men who are doing this are
essentially kids i mean many of them are
teenagers um
many of them some of them are conscripts
and
they have been misled about what they're
doing and i think there is absolutely no
excuse for the brutality and horror that
they're committing but
we also have to recognize that they are
also in a kind of hell they were led to
believe that they were going in to
liberate ukraine from nazism they had
most of them had no idea what they were
going into no idea that they were even
going into ukraine and the next minute
they know they expected to be welcomed
with open arms and the next minute they
know they're having to slaughter
children children who look just like
them some of whom speak russian some of
whom might even be related to them or
friends of people they know
so i do
in the midst of this horror well we do
all want anyone who has committed a war
crime to pay for that war crime we also
have to remember that
so far it looks as though maybe 10 000
russian boys have been slaughtered have
lost their lives for apparently no
reason their mothers everybody who knows
them will be devastated i think putin
simply thinks he has the entire male
population of russia to use as a
sacrifice in this war he doesn't care if
they can and fodder or not and in my
view that's another of the war crimes
that he's committing essentially
disposing of his young boys and young
men
in a way that is just utterly
reprehensible
uh let's uh turn away from ukraine for a
moment uh have a look at the observer in
this story about um well really the
tories turning their their back as it
were on on rishi sunak because of his
handling of the cost of living uh crisis
matthew take us into this
yeah they fear a pole disaster because
of high taxation uh taxes are
[Music]
not a complete record high but very very
high
um the tories uh say
with some legitimacy that the reason for
this is we've had to pay for an
unprecedented pandemic
as well as
uh the war in ukraine um but i think his
critics rightly point out that the way
that he has
configured his statement is to
penalize people at the very bottom of
society and i think that's a mistake the
problem with asking for lower taxes
of course is that it means higher
borrowing and borrowing costs are very
high we'll pay 83 billion pounds in
interest this year that's almost double
the amount we spend on defense um and
borrowing as a proportion of gdp is very
close to 100 percent uh so
it's it's a very difficult balance
assuming that to strike on the overall
fiscal picture and i do think it's
difficult for him to to start cutting
taxes unless he's prepared to cut them
on the very poorest
and make sure that they're slightly
higher on on those of us who can afford
to pay them and christina the express
has an idea way for him to uh claw back
and and cut taxes um to seize back some
of that fraudulent money that uh was uh
loaned covered loans fortunately taken
out
yes well lord anu who resigned um as i
think of a kind of
anti-fraud somehow i can't remember
exactly what he's called but something
along those lines over the 37 billion
pounds that it's alleged was um
freudian fraudulently taken by uh
businesses under the the covert
scheme
he
that there are you know thoughts that if
we could claw that back then that would
help and if we could claw that back that
would help and certainly there does seem
to have been major financial
mismanagement in relation to uh the the
covid scheme just as there was in
relation to ppe and
a lot of extremely lucrative pp
contracts going into people's pockets
and and this would help but it's a kind
of eye-catching headline that doesn't
really i mean it you know it shows that
there has been mismanagement and it
shows the scale of the problem but it
doesn't really solve the problem as
matthew says
i personally think i mean i'm no
economist but i i personally think that
this has to be treated as a war we are
literally uh you know involved in a war
now because we are giving weapons to a
country that is at war and that war is
having an effect on the cost of living
on energy prices and food prices on top
of the uh rise in inflation and rise in
the cost of living that was already on
the way and i think what rishi sunak and
some members of the cabinet simply don't
realize is that the scale of the pain
for many people in this country and
essentially the poorest people in this
country will be absolutely horrific and
i think you know lobbying if you pee off
fuel duty and reducing that on
insulation or or you know whatever fancy
schmancy thing he's offering to people
with who are homeowners just won't go
anywhere near the scale of the problem
and it does make the tories look
extremely cruel and i think it's been a
shock to rishi soon like in the last
week he sounded very petulant in a
number of his interviews because i think
he thinks you're sure we've got to do
this he if you haven't lived
near the poverty line and he clearly
hasn't then you have no idea of how this
is going to hit people and it's i mean i
think lots of
normal people on normal incomes are
really panicking about their energy
bills sunday times um and this story
about the refugees ministers promising
to to process visas for uh ukrainians
fleeing their country within 48
hours and how optimistic are we about
this matthew considering the problems
that there have been thus far
i think pessimistic
is my uh dominant emotion seeing this i
think i think the whole thing has been a
scandal um i mean bigger picture i think
uh the uk government has done quite well
over ukraine in terms of equipping them
uh with military equipment certainly
willing to go further and push faster
than mackerel schultz and even joe biden
and we have been acclaimed i think
rightly for that the real recognition of
the stakes here and what it means to
appease uh vladimir putin but on the
refugee crisis i think the government
underestimated
the willingness of the british public
to welcome people fleeing this horrible
war and that was compounded by
administrative incompetence uh in the
home office and you know at last we have
a minister lord harrington setting a
target
uh for 15 000 people a week
uh to get uh visas within 48 hours um
sorry visas within 48 hours and 15 000 a
week
coming over and let's just see if if he
meets that target at least he's put his
neck on the line
yeah that when the scheme was launched
on march the 18th it was estimated then
that the home office would be able to
process 10 000 visas in in the first
week and we know what happened there but
the question has been raised though
christina as to why visas should be
necessary at all
well i think i think it's fine to have
some kind of minimal check but we do
have to remember that almost all the
refugees coming into the country are
women and children because the men if
they're a fighting age have to stay
anyway so they're either elderly men or
women and children and i think it's
disgraceful actually to make people who
are fleeing a waffling the kind of thing
we talked about a few minutes ago where
children are literally being slaughtered
and tortured and used as human shields
as our adults all of which are war
crimes to make them not only fill out a
51-page form which is just ridiculous
but also clearly they were put through
an obstacle course where they were sort
of thrown from pillar to post
told to go from one
non-existent pop-up visa processing
place to another non-existent pop-up
visa processing place miles and miles
away i mean all of this sent the very
very strong message that they were not
welcome in this country and it was very
clear that we were trying to deter them
from coming here and i think pretty
patel
and also it has to be said boris johnson
because it wasn't just coming from
pretty patel the assumption was that we
didn't want to help that whole sort of
anti-immigration rhetoric and it's not
as though this is immigration it's it's
it's literally fleeing from a war
all of that was essentially about
blocking people from coming here and now
what the government has done is put
nearly all the responsibility onto
individuals and i just hope they do
provide some kind of infrastructure
support because people will need more
than families looking after them they'll
need proper access to healthcare
education indeed indeed and it remains
to be seen if the refugees minister um
will be able to keep his promise and
that is to process uh
visas within 48 hours we shall we shall
see on that let's move on to the um
sunday telegraph and this story about
our nuclear station ambitions uh the
prime minister's plans
matthew
every year very very important story um
first paragraph we're going to build up
seven new nuclear power stations as part
of a expansion of homegrown energy
i think security of energy supply
is of such critical importance for our
for our country uh in a geopolitical
context that's ever more uncertain
we now have a uh war of course uh in
ukraine uh but there is an alliance a
growing alliance between putin and xi
jinping of china uh it's gonna be of
such importance and i think you can see
that from the fact that germany has been
a real drag on western solidarity
because of its strategic dependence on
russian natural gas engineered of course
masterminded by gerhard schroeder who
became putin's bag man and has been one
of the most disgraceful western
politicians of of my lifetime italy also
tremendously dependent so i think this
is a good
um long-term plan and i wish it's a it's
a clean energy
um
security robustness of supply i wish
british politicians had done more of
this earlier
matthew
thank you and christina we have run out
of time see you in the 11.